SEE IF HE CALLS ME BACK.
>> I HAVE NO DOUBT, JOHN ROBERTS
, KEEP PRESSING.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR SARAH SANDERS JOINS
ME NOW PERIGEE IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
, FAITH, FREEDOM, AND THE
FIGHT OF OUR LIVES INSIDE THE
TRITE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
ALWAYS GREAT TO TALK WITH YOU.
YOU AND I WERE TOGETHER AND NOW
IT IS DAY TO SINCE THIS BOB
WOODWARD INFORMATION HAS COME
OUT.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THINGS MIGHT HAVE BEEN DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
I WANT TO ASK YOU FIRST, WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON WHAT THE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS AS SAYING
THAT HE WOULD’VE SUGGESTED TO
THE PRESIDENT HE NOT DO THIS.
AFTER ALL, BOB WOODWARD HAD
ALREADY WRITTEN SOME STUFF THAT
WASN’T POSITIVE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> I DON’T THINK THE CHIEF CHIEF
OF STAFF IS NECESSARILY WRONG,
BUT HONESTLY, HARRIS, I DON’T
CARE WHAT BOB WOODWARD HAS
DISABLED TO ME HE IS JUST
ANOTHER LIBERAL MEDIA MOGUL OUT
THERE TRYING TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT DOWN.
I THINK EVERY TIME HE WRITES A
BOOK, HE WRITES IT FOR ONE
PURPOSE.
HE WANTS TO SELL BOOKS SO HE’S
LOOKING FOR THE MOST NEGATIVE
LIGHT HE CAN TO PORTRAY THIS
PRESIDENT.
FRANKLY, I DON’T HAVE TO READ
HIS BOOK BECAUSE I SPENT TWO AND
A HALF YEARS SERVING ALONGSIDE
THE PRESIDENT.
I KNOW WHO HE IS.
I KNOW THAT HE LOVES THIS
COUNTRY, AND I KNOW THAT HE IS
CONSTANTLY FIGHTING FOR THE
COUNTRY, AND THE PEOPLE TO
DEFEAT THE LIBERAL MOB THAT IS
OUT TO DESTROY US.
IT’S THE REASON FRANKLY THAT I
WANTED TO WRITE THE BOOK THAT I
DID SPEAKING FOR MYSELF BECAUSE
I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THE REAL
STORY AND SEE THE REAL TRUTH
BEHIND WHO DONALD TRUMP AS AND
HOW MUCH HE LOVES THIS COUNTRY
AND ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HE IS
DOING TO HELP KEEP OUR COUNTRY
GREAT AND MOVE US FORWARD.
>> NOT TO MISS IT, SARAH, YOUR
BOOK IS HITTING AT A CRITICAL
TIME AS WELL AND YOU ARE ABLE TO
PUT THAT MESSAGE OUT THERE TOO.
WE WILL POP IT UP ON THE SCREEN
AS WE GO TO THIS.
CARL BERNSTEIN WHO BROKE THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL WITH BOB
WOODWARD SAYS TRUMP COMMITTED A
KIND OF HOMICIDAL NEGLIGENCE BY
DOWNPLAYING THE PANDEMIC AND HE
CLAIMS THE AUDIO RECORDINGS ARE
EVEN MORE DEVASTATING THAN THE
NIXON TAPES.
HE DIDN’T STOP THERE.
WATCH.
>> IF YOU LISTEN TO HIM COVER UP
THIS BRAVE GRAVE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE GREAT
PRESIDENTIAL FELONIES OF ALL
TIME.
MAY BE THE GREATEST PRESIDENTIAL
FELONY AND WE HAVE THE SMOKING
GUN TAPE OF THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTING THE FELONY.
>> SARAH, I CAN ALMOST SEE YOU
STILL STANDING BEHIND THAT
LECTERN AND WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
AT A WHITE HOUSE PRESS BRIEFING
TO THAT?
>> THINK HIS COMMENTS ARE
RIDICULOUS.
THAT THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T WANT
PEOPLE TO PANIC, HE DIDN’T WANT
OUR ECONOMY TO COLLAPSE.
IF ANYBODY IS GUILTY OF NOT
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE PANDEMIC
IT’S DEMOCRATS THAT WERE SO
FOCUSED ON IMPEACHMENT AND
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT WHILE HE
WAS ACTUALLY TAKING ACTION LIKE
STOPPING TRAVEL FROM CHINA, AND
MOBILIZING OUR COMMUNITIES TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES, AND PPE GEAR
AND VENTILATORS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT HOSPITALS AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS NEEDED.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK ACTION WHILE
DEMOCRATS WERE BUSY TRYING TO
DESTROY HIM.
I THINK IF HE WANTS TO TAKE SOME
COMMENTS ON WHO WAS NEGLIGENT, I
THINK HE HAS ANOTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE HE SHOULD FOCUS HIS FIRE
ON.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO
FASCINATING, AND I WONDER IF OUR
VIEWERS CAUGHT THAT, YOU DIDN’T
GO FOR THE PERSON WHO WAS NOT IN
OFFICE, JOE BIDEN WITH YOUR
COMMENTS RIGHT THEN, YOU TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE FOCUSED ON IMPEACHMENT WHO
HAD THE RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
JOBS TO HAVE MAYBE DONE
SOMETHING REGARDING THE PANDEMIC
.
THAT IS FASCINATING.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ALSO ABOUT THE
MESSAGING GOING FORWARD.
JOHN ROBERTS JUST REPORTED THAT
WE COULD SEE IF YOU WERE DAYS OF
THIS, MAYBE NOT ATOP THE
HEADLINES WITH THE BOOK HASN’T
COME OUT YET.
THEN YOU WILL SEE THE FOLLOW-UP.
WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU THINK SHOULD
BE COMING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD KEEP
THEIR FOCUS WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
.
IT NEEDS TO BE EXACTLY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID, LAW AND ORDER.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT MAKING OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE.
MAP TO TALK ABOUT MOVING OUR
COUNTRY FORWARD.
HE NEEDS TO KEEP OUR FOCUS ON
SAFETY, SECURITY, AND PROSPERITY
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THAT’S WHAT THE PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT.
THEY WANT TO KNOW THEY CAN WALK
DOWN THE STREET AND NOT BE
ATTACKED.
THEY WANT TO KNOW THEY CAN GO IN
AND OUT OF BUSINESS, THAT THEY
CAN DROP THEIR KIDS OFF AND
THEY’RE GOING TO GET A GOOD
EDUCATION AND THAT THEY WILL
HAVE A JOB TO GO TO ONCE THEY
DROP THEM OFF.
THAT WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT AND THAT’S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON.
HE HAS A GREAT RECORD OF ALMOST
FOUR YEARS OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
HE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE OF WHAT HE’S DONE IN
THOSE FOUR YEARS, AND WHAT HE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO ONCE
REELECTED IN NOVEMBER.
>> SARAH SANDERS, HER NEW BOOK
IS OUT.
ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU, THANK